what a good evening so many of you have
been my students in classes and you have
been exposed to supply chain concepts
and some of you have not so this time
this is the last lecture so that I'm
going to leave with you hopefully good
dosage of supply chain principles and
for those of you who have taken my
classes this there was somewhat of a
review but also is looking at it in a
more structured way yeah so hopefully
everybody would benefit from this last
lecture yes the title that I want to
share with you is the triple a supply
chain now I think some of you may know
that I have written an article in the
late to 7200 for which has exactly the
same title on the triple a supply chain
in the Harvard Business Review I wanted
to use that same framework but hopefully
given more of the current thinking about
the subject and some of the latest
examples and perspective on how
companies as in companies enterprises in
both product companies or service
companies or any organizations need to
have at least three a kind of
characteristics I think this is
applicable whether you're talking about
producing a car on computer or whether
you are serving in need of some some
type of surfaces the triple-a concepts I
think hopefully would be useful yes so
why triple-a triple-a is necessary
mainly because I think it's also an
exciting title when you talk about
single-a and that's not exciting yeah
single a these days especially Coco Xie
GSP doesn't use ABC as grace but in
other parts of campuses that we do use a
and B and C and these days with great
inflation having an a is nothing to be
proud of ya you need multiple age so
that's why triple-a triple-a bonds is
usually considered to be a sign of
excellence and I do believe that
companies that want to be excellent in
supply chain type of companies or
service companies need to possess three
what I call properties and these three
properties all start with the letter A
and that's why i call them triple a
supply chain interestingly is that I
think those companies that have these
three properties would also have triple
a type of
performance in terms of excellence okay
so just to prepare you I wanted to show
you maybe some recent studies studies in
203 that was jointly conducted by
stanford university and insead with also
participation from accenture which of
course for whether a lot of fun and show
have been that's important the study was
looking at whether companies who are
considered to be excellent in supply
chain performance and by supply chains
are usually what I meant is like
inventory turn speed cycle time cause
that kind of performance related to how
well you support your operations and
whether those would be related to
financial ultimate market performance so
this is the two things that we want to
know is that if you work hard and
getting cycle time down and inventory
turn good and so on would you be
rewarded is it related actually in the
perfect performance in the market and so
the simple relationship that we look at
is if a company has either improved in
your supply chain performances or
decline or maintain the same level what
happened to their market cap and there
are four kinds of companies in this
diagram here versus bike or supply chain
leaders these are companies that have
always perform well in the beginning of
the 90s in the second part of the 90s
companies that are core transformers are
those that did not perform well that the
later on they have improved leg are the
ones that have always performed below
industry average and the decliners used
to be performed well in the beginning of
the 90s but then they have declined and
sure enough there is a correlation the
correlation is that indeed those
companies that seem to perform well in a
supply chain have also enjoyed higher
than industry average in market caps and
of course the decliners have been
heavily penalised by the market because
of the performance so there is no clear
cause sanity relationship but definitely
there is a correlation similarly a some
colleagues of mine at Georgia Tech has
done some study looking at the SoCo
supply chain glitches by glitches what
they meant is that there were some
reported reported problems that these
companies have either because of
shortages or because of something is not
enough
pacity running down and they found that
those glitchers oftentimes resulted in
significant underperformance compared to
a comparable company in the same sector
so they pair them up and found that even
before or after those incidents there
are significant significant
underperformance as a result of these
glitches so all these means is that
companies do need to is important for
them to have good design good marketing
everything good setup leadership but you
also have to have a good engine to
deliver products to deliver orders to
satisfy your customers so today why was
it the case that it's so difficult for
companies to manage your supply chain
well now I think of course this is
self-serving I think there are three
major trends that make things difficult
yes and the 33 is an easy number to
remember so three things so the first
one is that is increasing uncertainty
the market is very uncertain in the
world is easy if everything is
predictable the second one is that
things are changing rapidly product life
cycles are shorter and shorter and so
yes you may found a good solution for
this product but the next product has
just come out you are at the end of the
product life cycle as soon as you
introduce a new product when I cycles
are three months long four months long
that's the kind of rapid changes that
we're talking about the technology were
also changing rapidly and third very few
companies can do it all that you have to
depend on many partners to produce a
product or make a service and so there
are many many players that you have to
depend on and those play players have
their own self-interests ooh and they
may not see eye to eye with you and you
have to make sure that their interest
somehow hopefully is aligned with yours
so because of these three challengers
that's why I think we need three
properties and those river bodies
remember yeah there is a test at the end
of this last lecture series there's a
last exam yeah which is what are these
three the third I think instead when the
world is so uncertain is very hard for
us to forecast what's going to be the
next product next season next fashion
and so instead of trying to
improve your forecasting maybe we should
ensure that we would just respond fast
and flexible responsive so agility is
the first property to replace the
ability to fork as well the second one
is what I called adaptability so when a
world is changing rapidly maybe there is
no perfect supply chain that you can
speak of yes it should we be
manufacturing in Mexico also we've even
factory in China that might be the best
solution for today and very rapidly when
you have a new technologies and when you
have a new product you may have to adapt
to a new way of running your process and
the third one is alignment meaning that
we have to make sure that we have to
identify both perhaps performance
measures we watch structures
risk-sharing kind of schemes to ensure
that our partners and we would be
synchronized to go north together to go
west together so that we would not be
going in opposite direction so those are
the three that I think are important so
let me elaborate a little more on these
three and the rest of the talk is more
about exactly what these three are about
and why in fact hopefully you'll see why
these three properties are important
first one agility so agility is
important because as I said that there
is no way you can exactly forecast the
world in perfection given the fact that
you have so many products and the world
is changing so rapidly so the way the
best way is to create a responsive
engine now here I think it's very very
nice framework that I think is useful is
the so-called Six Sigma process so Six
Sigma process which was using quality
control or which is used in general
management is actually quite applicable
in defining a responsive and egg Java
supply chain Six Sigma process says that
usually this is the industry world of
looking at what Six Sigma process is
about is to measure so first measure
measure to see what's happening in your
enterprise or your quality process so
you measure second is that from
measurement you derive what's wrong
potentially or whether things are going
in the right direction so you learn
about the process so once you learn
about the process you identify what
could be something that you need to do
to fix and when you respond you better
respond both respond with the right
action
so you analyzed though which is the
right action and you must respond fast
because if you are responding to slow
that opportunity would be over and once
you finish action you measure again to
see whether that action does it or
whether you now enter into a different
kind of stage and therefore when the
next time when you go and measure you
are comparing the so-called status quo
which is different from before so this
Sigma process I think is a good concept
for us to disease say if we want to be
an F ciao supply chain we must measure
we must measure to learn about the
changes fast rapidly so I p.m. has
called this kind of process this is an
IBM consulting type of qanskan
terminologies they call these sands and
response which is a way to do a charity
is to sense that Jo means you must know
before everyone else does whether
there's been some changes in pattern
changes in demand changes in supply
conditions fast fast dancing and also
fast response so sense and response was
the key however I think IBM of course
here this is the IBM term and I always
would not just use other people's
especially consultants concepts are
directly yeah so the value edible
professor is reprocessed and come up
with better things so and you see that
this is better I you hopefully you agree
with me what I think IBM is not enough
is that sense is not enough because most
of the times when people talk about a HR
supply chain sensing is important since
it means sensing finding out what's
going on how do we get sensors wow we
have to trap information with the final
what's going on in the market with find
out what's going on in the supplier
supplier suppliers customers customers
and you use all kinds of technologies
internet a business or a barcode RFID
radio frequency identification so you
use as many technologies as you can to
try to find out what's going on sensing
is important but only if you can make
sense out of sense don't you agree yeah
only after sensing all these information
you'll be overloaded you will be
overwhelmed because the best information
is useless unless you really understand
what's behind it so that's why I think
hands and response is insufficient here
is I think what is most powerful is that
you need to make sense out of sense it's
not because I'm just redundant I think
yeah you agree with me this is powerful
stuff sense out of sense why do we need
to make sense out of sense because in
general when you sense what's going on
in the market there are lots and lots of
noises and there are lots and lots of
bad data informations that you thought
you are sensing about what's going on
the market demand customers preferences
or could be polluted there is a lot of
distortion going on there is a lot of
blue wave going on those of you who have
taken the core operations remember this
term yeah go with everyone coming out of
this graduate school business must know
whoever i buy it yes if you don't know
what boobies yeah you cannot be awarded
a degree so Bowie Biz important what is
move a poop is a distortion of the
leading market so when people observe a
signal they reprocess it and they
oftentimes exaggerate or somehow
distorted signal so that when the signal
is passed on to another stage is
dishwater how can you just light any
sense if you sense without sense you
would be misled and there would be a lot
of gas signals you need to know who is
your customer really your customers
maybe that customers if you know truly
your customers you would use different
sense out of it she's very different
sense yeah I remember that a few years
years ago I was invited to be a keynote
speaker at a very big major conference
imagine conference so that's my field
and so I was a kid speaker so i was very
excited to give a keynote but the later
on i discover that before my speech this
conference organizer has organized
another another keynote speaker ahead of
me so EG the sebastian conference room
could be better than I am yeah the pies
dangerous oh yeah I'm the real expert so
I find out I find out that it was magic
johnson lady chosen was the other
keynote speaker so i said she what does
magic johnson know about supply chain
how could he be a keynote speaker ahead
of me
I thought maybe they want to warm up the
podium have magic Johnson warm up the
podium warm up the audience so that they
would be ready to receive the real
message coming from me of course yeah
fascinating thing he said I think I
learned something from magic wands I
really learned something from me before
CDs know much about supply chain but he
gave a lecture a short lecture about 15
minutes long kind of a speech that I
really have learned something from him I
am I not morally so what magic transit
area said everyone I'm no surprising
expert and I don't know why they invited
me to speak yeah but anyway I have a
simple message to you the simple message
is that you thought you knew your
customers you may not that's it there is
simple knowledge a lot of people thought
they knew their customers and when they
read signals interpret and sends you may
not know exactly your customers and so
he shared with the experience he said
after I retired from basketball and I
have money to invest I invested in one
of the investments that I made is in
cinemas I invested in cinemas building
cinemas and cinemas these cinemas I like
to invest cinemas in inner-city inner
city because oftentimes generously kids
and young people or people were deprived
of having a cinema they oftentimes have
to travel to downtown expensive places
upwards to watch movie so he wanted to
invest in inner city to have silver so
that the inner city people can have
access to Genoa but of course he didn't
know anything about cinema so he
purchased a property is 00 cinema and
old place and try to remodel it into a
cinema and because he has no knowledge
about cinemas so he hired an expert this
expert this manager has 35 years of
experience of running chambers so good
yeah we have an expert to take care of
this yeah so that person called a short
and do all the remodeling and take care
of things so the night before yo did
indeed opening night Magic Johnson went
to the cinema and chap get things out
and he walk around how everything seems
to be in recorder and so he's excited
about this new opening of his first
cinema and then he stopped at the food
store as you know we have food is very
important in cinemas that's how they
make money is selling you of popcorns
and disorders yes
at the ice creams candy bars and he
champ Wow who fully stuffed yeah fully
stocked with candy bars etc and then he
discovered that there will be 50 hot
dogs and Magic Johnson asked his
managers only 50 hot dogs did you notice
that it seemed slow isn't it we have a
scene where they can he sit hundreds of
people and this manager says that mr.
Johnson trust me i have 35 years of
experience much more than you of course
you have zero yeah so trust me cinema
people don't come to watch a movie
eating hot dogs people come to a cinema
have popcorns have Kenny Bosh and so
does they don't come here to eat hot
dogs 50 is more than enough guess what
the next day even before the movie began
they ran out they ran out of stock of
hot dogs and so very close in Spanish
that the manager thought that he knew
the customers but in fact it turns out
the concentrator the bulk of the
customers who came to watch the movie in
history theater where people who of
course could not afford to have a nice
dinner after a movie or before the movie
if you are in a nice downtown area
subvert kind of cinemas people watch a
movie and then they go out to eat or
have another snack a nice nice nice nap
the bar so of course while they're in
the cinema they don't eat meal they they
would have just a popcorn the hall and
soda because they are going to have a
meal or either before after but a lot of
the customers of Magic Johnson's cinema
were people who could not afford to have
a meal plus a movie so for them that
entertainment is the movie and the MU
must be together that's what they can
afford and I thought is a very nice way
to have a meal when you spend money
already on the ticket of the movie and
so that's a very simple as a powerful
lesson you thought you knew the
customers may not and that's why you
need to make sense out of sense so here
is what i think is a powerful revision
of IBM sends in response
it's sensible sense and responsive
response I like it yeah it's very
powerful I'm going to trademark I'm
going to train my peers so that anybody
who used it now have to pay me yeah so
what is sensible Sanchez moment sense
when you sense you sends information
about what the market was the supplied
with the condition but I must say just
mentioning to you is that you could set
up a lot of antenna so the preparedness
means that you set up a lot of antenna
to find out what's going on yap market
conditions we know supplier is a day
late we know but you must make knowledge
out of that information so that's the
sensible sense maybe some of them are
noises you throw away don't use it
sensible sense so this is the activation
part which is once the data comes in you
have to create intelligence and
smartness of it second portion is the
response when you talk about response
companies also invest a lot in extra
capacity supplier relationship but again
until the action happens that you can
indeed respond fast you response is no
use yes unless you can have fast
response there is always that I remember
there was a common joke in the Silicon
Valley in 1999 there was a comment job
that people say why do people have to
spend so much effort and money to deal
with y2k why is no in 1998-99 a lot of
companies invested a lot of IT budgets
to prepare for y2k so the common saying
was that why should we worry about y2k
what we need to do is to have a very
fast information system so that as soon
as New Zealand hit y2k you have
information immediately knowing the apt
ability they sink or it ain't no tell
you this is the country intact what is
the problem yeah what kind of things we
need to do that is a very interesting of
the user Joe Capozzi it's it's a say is
it's a good strategy if your response is
so fast if you can have in eight hours
you can change your information systems
then of course then don't know
invest in anything now just wait until
you watch it if New Zealand does until
the country is intact and you don't need
to do anything so sense and response
your response is only good if you are
responsive as if you are fast so I think
the color portion is the one that most
companies miss which is what I meant is
that you need sensible sense and you
need responsive response so that's about
it yeah so those of you who have taken
the course in the information that the
ology cause remember the company Zara
this company is an amazing company and
because i think they are truly an agile
company with sensible sends and
responsive response so they are able to
get information fast from the market and
they're able to utilize the information
to begin to knowing what the fashion
trends are and then manufacturer fast
manufacture and distribute fast
distribution is vast distribution is
amazingly fast within zarar every day
they are distributing everything out of
to distribution centers and because
speed is important which is why this
company has a nickname or a Wall Street
Journal quorum fashion koderma fashion
on demand that you could create fashion
in the quick short time another example
is again for those of you who african
that cause remember the 7-eleven japan
7-eleven japan is a fascinating amazing
company which also have sensible sense
and responsive response how do they too
sensible chance i'll give you two
examples and you would be impressed by
this company 7-eleven Japan what they
did is that a lot of company says that
while sense sense is easy for a retailer
you just get porno sales data quickly
you get part of selected quickly and
send it back to the headquarter so that
we know today is heaven up by selling
tomorrow maybe Google Kohler selling and
then you replenish fast that's the
walmart kind of a strategy is to get
porn of sales data fast process them
send them back to the distribution
center at the distributions and the
replenish is fast so that would be good
enough yes but 7-eleven japan decided
that that is just sense we need to have
sensible sense sense emotions would be
what one example that that that really
is truly a very powerful one and and a
few of you may still remember but it's a
year ago so maybe not too many of you
remember so you still be enjoying this a
excellent example now so what happened
is that about seven years ago
7-11 started to sell very well lady
stockings your pantyhose was selling
like crazy they're very good selling
said pantyhose any 7-11 Japan which of
course year is weird you out by with the
Japanese want to buy pendejo at the
convenience store and not at a
department store they were the number
one in the country bash seller of
pantyhose part of them are selling in 10
7 11 so one of the vice president of
7-11 Japan's proposed to the CEO
proposed to the CEO say hey look mr.
Tsuzuki yeah so Sam did you know
that we are doing so well in ladies
talking I think there is an opportunity
that this is sense and less responded by
sensing yeah so the response is that
let's create a larger cosmetic section
cosmetic section to sell lipsticks and
shampoo to take advantage of the fact
that we doing so well in ladies talking
mr. Suzuki is very smart man miss Suki
says that sounds like a good idea but
before we move yeah of course yeah he
wasn't using my terminologies but it's
the same I think yeah so so I'm sure he
would agree with me so this is that we
have to make sure that what we are
sensing is correct we are sensing this
correct so go and make sure you who are
the customers who are the customers
buying and the Hawks because if they are
women then of course here we expand the
cosmetic section now at first this vice
president says that that seems like a
dumb question who are the customers of
pantyhose of course they're women yes
since obvious but in Japan you dare not
challenge the boss yeah you don't say
what a dumb question instead you say
what a great question is the Suzuki Wow
brilliance wow yeah how come I didn't
think of it so we go and do it so so
this vice president ran off and research
and what he found as you know in
7-eleven Japan they actually when they
check out at a checkout counter not only
do
wave just check scan your item so as to
trap your part of sales data but they
also are required this is a very very
unique retail changing in the world
every checkout counter person that hello
or the hunter person here has to
estimate the age of the customer and
then inputted so they are required
because they know it's so important to
know what customers not only are we
interested in sales we are interested in
who are customers behind that sale so
don't ask me you have to ask made by
classified in the group so they have a
special special kind of machine checkout
machine that says 20 to 30 30 to 40 40
50 so you have to ask me okay this
version 25 years old and so you have to
put any better and the second thing is
that you secondly you have to estimate
the gender of the customer yes so you
estimate okay probably not too hard yeah
so you can ask of course you cannot say
via can you tell me your gender & age
before you buy the sushi ya know so you
estimate so they were having this data
so when mr. Tsuzuki asked that question
is actually very easy they went back
immediately doing some analysis to the
surprise that the bulk of the sales of
the pantyhose happened between seven to
nine p.m. at night and a lot of the
customers were men strange isn't it
Steve can yeah you seem perplexed yeah
yes well yeah well okay good job good
one yeah so so in fact there was a
reason of course because there a lot of
them ajep Japan we still have a lot of
male working and female staying home
kind of Steel this is the social norm
it's always very very convenient for the
wives asked husband's where go out on
the way back home this is what most of
them also commute to work that's a
majority are not driving is not as kind
of common yeah so every subway station
train stations there is a 7-eleven store
so on the way Cole money yeah why don't
you pick up the half a dozen of these
any hoes black and size 38 yeah some I
don't know what that with its number
I am NOT a customer you can tell ya so
so they they would shop for their wives
and the Japanese work hard very late
long hours so by the time they got
homeless seven o'clock eight o'clock
nine o'clock and they are exhausted but
their wife asked them to pick up any
also they have to stop by and pick up in
yours so once they find out this is
putting intelligence in the sense mr.
Tsuzuki ask the vice president should we
still expand the cosmetic section know
where the vice president says no need
now let's move all the pantyhose next to
the beer section C sensible sense would
create smart response yet if you are not
fast if you are not fast and you're not
responsive you will fall into the victim
of what happened to Erickson in the year
2000 when they will say fire in the
Albuquerque the fire not destroy but
it's just a small fire in a clean room
of the philips semiconductor factory of
course it's a very very clean room you
know even if it's not a big fire but
once the fireman came in with the hose
and water yeah you are disabled for a
long time so nokia was able to identify
the informations and the co next day
immediately sent a squad of vice
president out because they have been
burned before yeah so they know that
it's important for them here to react by
knowing what exactly is going on so you
need sense and then merely develop a
strategy to take advantage of the extra
capacity of Phillips in Singapore and I
Dobin change the design of the product
so that I can make use of other
processes and in the end they did not
suffer any shortages but ericsson did
not do sense nor good response because
they didn't sense the way it work you
said the air its and people also learn
about the fire and so they asked
Phillips yeah what happened do you have
a severe fire and the Phillips people of
course has an interest to kind of try to
be emphasized the seriousness of the
problem and so the incident was told by
Philip see ya there was a fire but it
was put out
in less than half an hour so is no big
deal please go back to sleep yeah don't
worry here and they at a time when they
learn about the seriousness of this
Feynman problems is too late all the
capacity of Phillips have been taken by
Nokia so Erickson suffered 500 million
u.s. dollars lost 4.5 billion from nurse
because of when fire so that's important
second adaptability adaptability I use
an example that some of you in the
global operations was remember is loser
in the 80s and the 90s loosen use a
strategy of the supply chain of
concentrated manufacturing concentrate
manufacturing means that they would
concentrate manufacturer in a single
location in that case in Oklahoma City
why because they said most of the
customers are in the US and most other
suppliers are in the US so let's take
advantage of economies of scale risk
pooling centralized procurement
centralized kidding centralized
manufacturing that's the way to take
control of the technologies in the 90s
they discover their that would not work
that would not work because both of us
are biased at MU to Asia and the fastest
growing market is in Asia is in India is
in Taiwan is in China so what they found
is that George foodie vice presidents of
manufacturing once told me is that they
have a supply chain strategy that sucks
and because they would fly all these
components from a sure to Oklahoma City
store them and then eventually put them
together a final example keep them catch
them and then fly them back to Asia and
it cost at a time and the worst thing is
that they all did not earn any frequent
flyer miles so it was loose loose loose
yeah so anyway so they they change they
change the supply chain in 1996 they
move manufacturing to Taiwan a movement
attention to Taiwan because then the
Asian hub can surf the Asian market and
can do the procurement there's no need
for them to fly things around it was a
very successful strategies but then I
think adaptation is never a there's no
end to an adaptation you should honestly
at that because the world is changing
all the time so when the technology is
in early days and the content Sheila
supply demand the losing strategies of
focused manufacturing focused in
Oklahoma City work like a charm
later on as demand becomes more
widespread and suppliers are also
widespread they have this regional
expanded network strategy that also is
fine but when the technology is fully
mature what happened is that a lot of
the outsourced manufacturers can do the
job equally well and they have really
lower cost structure so what Louise I
don't have to do is to change the value
chain by outsourcing you don't need to
do it all yourself which is what
loosened it what loosened it is that
they drastically started outsourcing
recently because they recognized that
holding on to manufacturing is the wrong
strategy when the technology is fully
mature so you need to adapt another
example of adaptation is a company
called pascal which is a very successful
steel manufacturer they are not number
one in the world in terms of size but
their profits is larger than number two
number one two three four and together
so the largest that they are number four
in size but if you add the top the top
five except Vasco at the total profits
or school has larger profit than the
rest of it so this company is successful
well there's some very interesting
lessons and I think we can learn from
pasco in the early days Pasco use a
centralized strategies so called
continuous casting technology why
because that save energy and also is a
very very good process to enable you to
do the steel manufacturer steel casting
and the muse has been concentrated in
Korea because the bulk of the demand of
course in the early days korea was going
through rapid reconstruction after the
Second World War and so very significant
demand from career but what happened is
that today the world's changed the world
has changed because the ingredients the
input to Mickey steel is not in Korea
yeah they're in Brazil they are in
australia and the course has been going
up so controlling the source is
important second is that transportation
cost has also skyrocketed and china is
hungry for steelers we all know in China
even though the supply of Steel has
increased but the demand of Steel has
increased even much higher so complete
with China is very hard so what parts
cook you have to do is that the oh
concentrated supply chain strategy has
worked very well for them but not
anymore when you have the compete for
inputs and when transportation cost is
much higher than before so what they did
is this integration so they
disintegrated their supply chain by
having now factory's forming joint
ventures with the key suppliers and all
in Brazil in Australia where the iron
ores are so they build a lot make them
in the crude or steel and then to the
finishing in the market market being the
US and China of course there's some in
Korea but because the big markets
rapidly increasing markets are in the US
and China why do I have to bring all
these iron ore and core go into career
and build them and then you have to ship
them to china and us very expensive
remember transportation costs so
adaptation is another very important
strategies and costco is a successful
company because they never just live
with a single solution they attacked
finally anime is very important
alignment this importance is because as
we depend on our partners to make
products and services it's not
sufficient for you to say i am really
excellent company and i do the vast
operations because the weakest link of a
supply chain defiance is approaching if
you have a supply chain and some of the
partners are not working well you would
be vulnerable so the weakest link here
we are talking about supply chain too
surprising competitions and we must make
sure we win win win meaning everyone
wins not just one wins always wins yes
so so importance to have win winter
absolutely important so one example is
prius PS of course is a very successful
hybrid that we all know but when toyota
introduced the prius first initially
seven years ago eight years ago priya's
was not kind of a sure win at that time
toyota introduced bharat talking to the
dealers hey mister dealership we want
you to sell prius will the proxy out we
don't know care it's very risky who
knows the Americans would they care
about this fuel-efficient car well it's
very risky and plus
the worst thing is that a lot of the
parts were not coming with camry or with
the growler so there is a separate set
of spare parts just a battery charger is
very expensive so what to order it says
is that the retailer's I want dealers I
want you to sell Prius you don't know
what the product was hell or not but of
course once I ship you the Prius
according to the two loaders agreement
like other cars as soon as i ship you
own it you pay me if it doesn't sell it
has your problem yeah yeah I did you pay
me first and plus you have to invest in
the spare parts yet invest in the
charges and a lot of new equipment so
what happened is that this is an equal
and equal risk the risk is of course
much higher for the small little dealers
compared to a giant company like to
order who can absorb the risk much
better so the unequal risk means that
promoter could have their way because
they are powerful company and they can
say we are this is it yeah you have to
do it otherwise i won't kick you out of
the dealership network but they
recognize that the dealers would be
doing it watching Lee and they may not
work very hard for Prius they were
saying there you come in here don't look
at the piers yeah let me show you Henry
or corolla equally good so there the
incentive would not be aligned if they
create this unequal risk sharing so to
the credit of the rotor they modify this
they modify saying that for this product
only if you sell peers we take the risk
of the product for other cars that's not
the case for other cars camry as soon as
we should be coming to you you on the
product and you cannot sell it you mark
down you do whatever you want that's
your problem you pay me first but for
prayers i take ownership of the products
i have the product capped at the
distribution center and near the dock
near the port when you have successfully
so pious I'll send it to you otherwise
you have you don't have any risk you
only sell you're an agent and that is
the balance of the risk and it worked as
a result the incentives were aligned and
the dealers are much more willing to
work hard to get those products because
they also know there is always guy I
have much better margin because I don't
need to have to borrow money to finance
the inventory for this car
this car I have much better imagine
helling so the dealers are incentivized
to work hard and then there was a sigh
bonus it turns out the side bonus was
that if Toyota has been using the old
regime old methods of sending asking the
dealers to take ownership what do you
think would be the estimate that they
would use in terms of whether we should
send more cars to the nor piece to the
northwest and the west coast they would
use no better estimate except just use
camping or Corolla that's what we are
selling so if the if the west coast
people north California there's five to
six percent of the total US market of
camry is in north korea california we
send five to six percent prius to them
if the South years which is the big oil
state taxes Florida has twenty percent
we sent three percent there but because
this time they're not sending things out
there centralizing they will luck out
because it turns out Prius demand is
very different from the rest of the US
for the rest of the cash turns out that
in the previous case north California
takes twenty-five percent of the prius
market so we not Californians are very
she anxious yeah much more conscientious
in the rest of the country and in
southeast only got six six percent so in
this case to go to lock out because if
they have sent it how to do the wrong
place you can imagine that it is South
years they have to do a lot of Martin's
and then the north in the indicated
Northern California they have to fight
get peers so this is important risk risk
another example of alignment is
so-called supplier happy yeah what is
the supplier up the supplier happens
usually today companies like their come
usually compare an HP all of them Cisco
or recognize they don't like inventory
nobody likes inventory so they shut up a
soco hop which is a warehouse next to
them very close to them and as the
suppliers to send him enjoy their but
they don't own the cisco would not only
meant over it yeah would not only meant
all that inventories to yours every
morning when I go and pick up then
becomes mine but so when you ship even
if you are a from the asia singapore
yeah you ship all the products is yours
you take ownership until I pick it so
that's very much like a vending machine
you have any machines as manufacturers
to make the products send the product
all the way to the vending machine they
still own the product until you pick and
get it so let's go there or like this
very much yeah because of course there
then did they don't have to buy the
inventory into the factory which there
you have to take ownership and subject
to the risk so they asked to supply to
bear the risk but this is not fair you
know gosh some suppliers of course if
you are in tell you don't this is not
that bad a deal to take ownership and
India usually doesn't take ownership
anyway they're strong enough to say no I
don't play this game but if you're a
small suppliers you have to play
according to the rule and yet at the
same time you have to borrow money to
finance inventory a small supplier has
to borrow money and a heavy heavy
interest rate but because you're a small
sometimes startup companies and you're
the financial inventory is very
expensive so in a way it's not fair
because the weakest player in the supply
chain is shouldering a much bigger
liability than cost yes and so some
statistical I got from a company called
world chain that says that in the 2000s
you know a lot of companies are actually
shifting the inventory burden to the
suppliers if you're a component
manufacturer supplier semiconductor they
were shouldering a lot more inventory
than before and there's a smaller guys
then down and yet they are borrow money
heavily so so this is not a good way to
run the supply chain so a new way is the
following a new way is that some
financial intermediaries used to be
silicon valley bank started sinking they
then created this solution what
surrogate valley bank says is that will
buy the inventory from this mortgage
will buy it because we are silicon
valley bank we can finance the inventory
at much better rate we are back so we
can borrow money at a much lower
interest rate than anybody else in a
supply chain and then we just purchased
finance the inventory and when down is
it we sell them to go so in a way
everybody's better off because the
interest rate the difference of interest
rate is sufficient for you to pay
silicon valley bank gave
and steal your better off so today GE
Capital is doing it UPS capital a lot of
companies are rushing in to do this
financial reengineering is to try to
correct some of the imbalance of the
liabilities so I think to some some up
and then I want to open up for some
questions is that I think 3a the first a
is important and the trick to do first a
well agility well is to do sensible
sense and responsive response yeah so
doctor sends it responds make make some
sense out of sense and response second
one adaptive adaptive means that we must
recognize there is a market condition
change there is the technology change
product lifecycle change and you may
have to change your solution in response
to those change and the third one is
alignment alignment means that we look
at the supply chain partners maybe we
have to change who is responsible for
what maybe we have to change the way we
share risk we share costs and we share
reward maybe we also have to expand the
notion of performance measures what is
the performance measures once we are
partnered and integrated we cannot
simply say this is my territory i
measure only my within my territory and
that's yours maybe we have to have some
joint ownership of some performance
measures because we're integrated
because we want to make sure we align
interest so that's alignment so three
things very simple first agility
sensible sends the response adaptive
adaptive based on market conditions or
product lifecycles technology cycles
alignment which is the exchange of
responsibility decision right sharing
risk and cost and rewards and redefining
performance measures to be those are the
three properties and hopefully come and
more companies would recognize these 3
a's to become triple a performance as
well thank you very much thank you
Kris coos yes sorry you've spoken to a
lot of these different companies I'm
paying back to the original chart that
you'd shown the district seen a leader
and a lagger what about those companies
in your opinion having perhaps spent
time with both of them what's the
difference between the two of them in
terms of their management orders their
practices I think there are certainly
yeah number one is that companies need
to recognize that supply chain matters
yes looking at supply chain looking at
00 order fulfillment process and not
just think that this is a necessary evil
yeah so that's number one so number two
is that usually what I found do
successful companies are where the sea
level people are the one
spending time understanding these order
for human processes understanding the
operations to try to create a
corporate-wide awareness and initiatives
yes and the third one is that who isn't
there's not a fixed target it's not like
yes we arrived there and so very happy
let's all celebrate here so is the
continuous range so it's clear mature
continuously kind the Kaiser on terra
firma mentality is to continuous
improvement in the necessary so I think
in a way you can say that a lot of these
our culture is a corporate culture the
company having the culture of looking
into the supply chain issues and not
delegated to save a we see level only
worried about the mergers acquisitions
and investments let somebody else manage
this actual delivery and making of the
products here so I think it's a in a
simple term simple way you say is there
is a culture a suprising culture yes
company that
is there any application for supply
chain theory I talked to I think the
global operations cause we we actually
have some discussions of companies such
as Amazon and and also ebay type of
companies yeah well the way you organize
your software it could be the way you
organize your software may be in a
modular structure so that you can easily
be flexibly customize the products where
you enter into the china market or India
market so you'll be able to quickly
customize your products which would
enable you to fit the needs of the local
markets and also have fast delivery so I
think software has similar even though
it's not tangible physical products but
you do need to have this type of speed
you do need to have this flexibility and
responsibility and even in the software
case you cannot be just by yourself you
get you have partners you need partners
and so you also have to align the
interests of the partners in the case of
Amazon of course the US Postal Service
UPS type of companies that they have
worried about the actual delivery and
Amazon when they went to Japan they had
to partner with the convenience store a
very successful venture today amazon
just dropped 1 billion dollar mark in
japan and the success of in japan is not
just purely ecommerce asia for amazon is
a very successful partnership with the
convenience store so that customers
would go to the web to order products
and pick up products after you have
order from amazon and pay also at the
convenience store so there's a very
interesting partnership model now you
have to make sure that a convenience to
are rewarded adequately there are in
order for them to be willing to be your
last smile but again it means that
software companies cannot live on only
themselves you may have also to lose
partners we have in our current course
in the strategy course we talk about
into it which also require partnerships
with other companies to provide an
extended service of the financial
services mortgage an idea and of course
not every such deal where they have done
well have been producing results but
game we are not cannot live in a kind of
a single enterprise mode you do need
this alignment so I think software very
much software service have very similar
principle except it may not be as
physically tangible yeah
very good kids thank you yeah